[Music]
mommy why you said doodles
Wow the luxury of having Mariah Carey as
a parent that's eight-year-old
Monro cannon killing the high note
challenge on tick-tock
thanks to her mom's stellar vocals Mimi
making a cameo in the video definitely
dressed for the occasion
Monroe is a social media star in the
making earlier this month in a hilarious
video
Mariah's mini-me threw a little shade at
everyone who can't sing like her mom I
[Music]
love it the singer's twins Monroe and
Moroccan whom she shares with ex-husband
Nick Cannon loved to sing along with
their mommies a few years back the 49
year old shared a video on Twitter of
the two singing background vocals - all
I want for Christmas is you
[Music]
20:18 Nick Cannon revealed CET that
Moroccan even wrote a Christmas song of
his own nothing goes to say this but my
son maybe like two years ago wrote a
song I know he's writing before he was
found he was turning five and he wrote a
Christmas song and I was really excited
this is my son's Christmas song no joke
he goes I saw your boobies on Christmas
Eve they were so beautiful I didn't
wanna leave it's my boy Rocky hilarious
but in all seriousness Nick did say that
the kids have some real musical talents
I mean my daughter's really picked up on
like you know one in in learn piano so I
kind of teach her a little bit when it
comes to piano my son's always been in
the drums so and then the fact that and
he's a like a little tech geek - so like
engineering and all that stuff he's into
the I could see him being a producer or
something like that but the fact that
you know they all have the musical
ability and they enjoy doing it even at
this early age it's really fun Mariah
also opened up the et about the twins
having the performance bug just like
their parents they want to be up on
stage like mommy I want a cop on stage
you do so I'll bring them onstage and I
have this little video that I show doing
always be my baby well this was during
the update or here we don't do that here
I'll figure out what we do when I go
back to the rehearsal area but um they
love to see that so sometimes they feel
like we want to come up on stage and so
I brought them on stage and a couple
places and what are you gonna do like
it's great to have that footage you know
I wish I had footage of myself when I
was little the first time I went on
stage and stuff so it's packing up for
that
[Music]